the 1968 US Olympic track and field team
is considered one of the greatest ever
assembled to represent the u.s. in the
Olympics they won 28 medals and set
eight World Records at the Games in
Mexico City
the team included some of the fastest
runners in the world at the time like
sprinters Tommie Smith and John Carlos
who made history when they accepted
their medals and then raised their fists
during the playing of the US national
anthem in a protest full of symbolism
and they almost didn't even show up that
year members of the team threatened to
stay home in protest and racist
treatment of black athletes in America
they will not participate in the 1968
Olympics in Mexico City unless something
is done about these terrible evils and
injustice the story of this silent
protest and the boycott that almost was
starts with the buttons all three medal
winners wore that day the Olympic
project for Human Rights
[Music]
the Olympic project for Human Rights or
Opie HR was founded in 1967 by
sociologist educator and former star
athlete dr. Harry Edwards it was a
coalition of prominent Olympic athletes
that threatened to derail American
Olympic glory by opting out of the games
to protest the racism and sports that
for decades had gone unaddressed in the
mid 20th century sports seemed to be a
leading example of improved racial
equality in the United States black
athletes like football player Kenny
Washington and baseball player Jackie
Robinson broke racial barriers by
joining professional leagues in 1946 in
1947 which until that point had been
White's only college and professional
sports teams
gradually integrated from their years
ahead of racial segregation legally
ending in the United States so the media
began to promote black athlete as a
symbol that racial democracy existed in
the United States
ataque Robinson then why can't a black
to make it and so it was kind of a
factor that was used to dismiss the
question of institutionalized racism but
in the 1960s the myth of racial progress
in America began to dissolve the civil
rights act ended legal segregation in
1964 but black Americans continued to
face institutionalized racism and police
brutality integration simply wasn't
successful in terms of improving black
people's lives and you needed to force
further change years of frustration
ultimately erupted in widespread violent
riots I think the further we get away
from that we underestimate the influence
of the riots the riots happened in a lot
of urban cities across America black
people still live in terrible
socio-economic conditions in the cities
and that was just as much a problem as
Jim Crow laws so how do you attract the
attention to that a growing black power
movement and black student movement in
the 1960s emboldened black athletes to
speak up about the racial injustice 'as
they endured off the field there's no
difference between
black-and-white athlete we're all out to
sweatin we run on two legs what's the
difference in the way society treats us
after we leave the track but with the
1968 Olympics coming up black athletes
saw an opportunity to push for change
the idea of a black boycott had been
around since 1959 and in various bits
and stops until you get to the Black
Power Conference in 1967 the black pilot
happens basically argue that you should
use any means possible to force the
government to pay attention to
institutionalized racism for Harry
Edwards that meant organizing the
Olympic project for Human Rights he
realized that he could use black sports
participation as a way to attract
attention to the problem the OU PHR had
five key demands among them being to
disinvite South Africa and Rhodesia two
countries practicing apartheid from
competing in the games the removal of
openly racist International Olympic
Committee president Avery Brundage and
hiring black coaches to US teams the
potential boycott became a hot topic in
the news and of debate among athletes
but we don't want to close the door on
Williams apartment in United States oh I
don't see a boycott in the months
leading up to the games in Mexico City
the OPH are kept members of the press
guessing whether they would attend or
not we will let you know about the
future of your Olympic team when we deem
it proper and when we feel that you can
handle that kind of information right
now we just don't think that you're
ready I'm when will come a determination
whether you Lee Evans and others will or
will not the boycott the Olympics I wish
I could tell you ultimately it came down
to a vote the decision was made that if
there wasn't really a kind of unified or
majority of that black athletes would
participate the boycott would be called
off because those who did boycott Mike
Tommie Smith would have been boycotting
a bank another black person simply would
have taken their place even though most
of the Opa charge demands remained unmet
the athletes headed to Mexico City with
plans to make their own demonstration if
the opportunity arose
which it did on October 16th following
the men's 200-meter final OPH our
members Tommie Smith and John Carlos won
gold and bronze respectively and Smith
set a new world record
after the race they solemnly approached
the medal stand she lists wearing black
socks accepted their medals and just as
the u.s. national anthem began to play
did this
for the full duration of the
star-spangled banner' Smith and Carlos
bowed their heads and each raised a
black gloved fist in the air to protest
the racial injustice in their home
country and show solidarity with those
fighting for equality
[Music]
the fists are not the only symbolic
gesture in this image as Tommy Smith
explained later the right glove
signifies the power within black America
the left glove signify black unity a
scarf that was worn around my neck
signified blackness John Carlos and me
wore black socks without shoes to also
signify our poverty
additionally John Carlos wore his jacket
unzipped a violation of Olympic
etiquette to show solidarity with
working-class Americans he also wore
beads to honor victims of lynching and
finally all three medal winners
including silver medalist Peter Norman
of Australia wore buttons reading
Olympic project for Human Rights there
were some boos in the stadium last night
this moment was the ultimate
manifestation of the work of Harry
Edwards and the OPH our two intersect
outspoken political activism with sport
and it ended Smith and Carlos is
Olympics the International Olympic
Committee suspended them Friday their
credentials were taken away and they
were told they could not stay in Mexico
they were dropped from the US Olympic
team and given 48 hours to leave Mexico
sports journalist Howard Cosell
criticized the US Olympic Committee's
decision in this fiery broadcast from
Mexico City
they say the games are sports not
politics something separate and apart
from the realities of life but the black
athlete says he is a human being before
he is an athlete that he wants equality
everywhere not just within the arena
Tommie Smith and John Carlos were saying
like I don't have to pay that American
Society we may be famous but we face the
same discrimination that other black
people do and we don't appreciate being
used as a way to counter the black
struggle coming out of black community
story
black athletes are black people have
multiple identities
I think colin kaepernick is representing
of voice in the black community which is
the same thing I think that Carlos and
Smith was saying that the black struggle
is more than just about integration and
assimilation it's also about empowering
this particular community and people
like Tommy Smith Harry Edwards John
Carlos came from poor black communities
which is why this protest on the Olympic
medal stand wasn't just about sports as
Tommy Smith explained to Howard Cosell
the next day do you think you
represented all black athletes from
doing this I can say I represented black
America I'm very proud to be a black man
and also to have won a gold medal and
this I thought I could represent my
people by letting them know that I'm
proud to be a black man
[Music]